bacon is
launching us into a new world it's a
world of scientific technology and it's
a world for which we must in large part
be grateful
it is a world that gives us medicine
it gives us iphones and laptop computers
and
uh the prosperity that we have
but it's also a world that gives us
great anxiety
about our place in the world about the
meaning of the world about the ground of
our moral judgments
[Music]
we might call bacon the father of modern
science but bacon never made any
distinct philosophical or scientific
discoveries in fact what bacon offers is
a
new picture of the world a new way of
seeing things he offers a program for
study and that's one of the reasons
we're going to read him is to see him
not so much as a scientist but
largely for his the imaginative
program and vision he gives to
philosophy and the philosophical
enterprise what is characteristic of
modern philosophy what makes it
different from medieval or ancient
philosophy
the first thing
is a severe
criticism of the previous tradition
not just
this thinker or that thinker or this
argument or that argument
what i'm talking about is a whole scale
repudiation of the entire pre-existing
order of knowledge and inquiry
and bacon
is very explicit about this
for let a man look carefully in all the
variety
of books with which the arts and
sciences abound
he will find everywhere
endless repetitions of the same thing
varying in the method of treatment but
not new in substance
and so much that the whole stock
numerous as it appears at first view
proves on examination to be but scanty
and for its value and utility
it must be plainly avowed that the
wisdom which we have derived principally
from the greeks is but like the boyhood
of knowledge and has the characteristic
property of boys
it can talk but it cannot generate see
the style
for it is fruitful of controversies
but barren
of works
number two then
bacon suggests because that whole
tradition is
sterile and barren of works and
disputatious
and
unproductive therefore we need a new
foundation
bacon tells us that the goal of this new
foundation
is not to understand nature but to
command nature
that's a very important point we've
already read that bacon says the goal is
generation
fruit
works not understanding but production
this is why bacon is sometimes called
the father of modern science because he
wants to give us a way of knowing how to
dominate and control nature for the
assistance of human beings
so bacon is at the front end of what
today we call scientific
technology using science to promote
technology
finally fourth the fourth element in
modern philosophy that we find in the
great installation is
uh bacon's promoting
of a new way of knowing
uh
bacon is focused on
human
knowledge
he's focused on the way in which humans
know
the world and bacon begins the great
inspiration by telling us that our
knowing powers have been so corrupted by
various things that he thinks we need a
new foundation and he wonders if
information of the senses he tells us
is
faulty
look at two railroad tracks
extending into the distance
it looks like the sides converge to a
point
our senses tell us that the tracks get
closer and closer together
but they don't
submerge a stick in water the stick
looks bent
but it isn't
bacon is profoundly
convicted by the idea that our
senses
falsify reality and you need to let this
sink in for a moment that challenge
we spontaneously say sometimes perhaps
it's obvious it's as obvious as the fact
that grass is green
but for the philosophers after bacon
the question arises
is grass green
and in fact what the science tells us
after bacon
is that the greenness in the grass is
not in the grass
the greenness in the grass is really
wavelengths of light that can be
measured by a spectrometer
the perception of greenness is purely in
us in the way our code our rods and
cones and the pigmentation in our eyes
translates the wavelengths of light into
a visual experience that we have in our
minds
wow
what does this mean
it means that the whole world of our
sense that we use to mark the
meaningfulness of our reality is
significantly undermined
bacon begins the epistemological turn in
modern philosophy
he introduces critical philosophy
and as we saw in the lecture
that involves criticizing our senses
and the ability for our senses to
reliably tell us about reality
that critique is going to continue in
the subsequent philosophers that we read
and it will become increasingly
aggressive
in its undermining our ability to rely
on the senses
and
arguably it reaches its end in nietzsche
who sees that that critique of the
senses is ultimately self-defeating
and it leaves us then with the question
of whether that challenging of sensory
knowledge was correct in the first place
it is true
that our senses vary with perspective
that different shades of light can make
things look differently that we can look
at things at a distance and close up and
see them at different sizes
but notice that we can only know that
our senses
fail by other senses
when you want to correct a false view
you take the stick out of the water and
notice it's straight
you follow the railroad tracks down and
notice that they do not converge
in the distance
and it may be that our senses are
our only real contact
with reality
you